Such as the "Arush conflict" "West World" is a complex
An epic mystery box of production that ends up discovering something much smaller
And more important are: personal
For this reason, despite the overwhelming prospect, that makes everything coherent is talks
How they were written and how they were applied. Today, I want to look at a conversation featuring the great "Anthony Hopkins".
Specifically, I want to see how Anthony Hopkins represents the scene and how each line of dialogue emerges in a fun way.
Imagine that I had gotten mad,
is not it ?
Lost my way?
We are simply concerned about how much changes you are making.
We want to preserve your heritage.
Heritage?
Well, for your information on the scene is that "Teresa Cullen" is the director of the operations of the park "West World" trying to stop
Or at least trying to disrupt the creation of "Anthony Hopkins" which is "Ford" for new stories for visitors,
Those stories that are generally going to hurt the park financiers.
It is clear that "Teresa" feels that the Ford project is a serious risk,
But instead of saying frankly to him, she said her words with kindness.
We want to preserve your heritage.
Heritage?
Well, that stand took seven seconds and it was fantastic. Following the response to the denial comment on her blunt kindness.
"Hopkins" in silence, passed through several feelings.
First, "deny" and then "discuss" the words in a fraction of a second. It is clear from the expression of his face.
Perhaps he should have protected his heritage. He may not have to be ambitious at this age.
Then "his smile and the scene highlights many different smiles and this smile" kindness "
He shows up in his face when he considers himself an attacker or someone who is insulting his intelligence.
As he laughs, his chuckle laughs like a fury.
He can only bear to look at her quick looks as though he is collecting his remains, and then he turns into a remarkable enemy.
You do not like that place so much. is not it ?
I've seen a lot of you come and come back over the years.
I can say who is enjoying the time here and who do not enjoy it.
What is amazing here is how the dialogue emerges as written.
In television interviews, Hopkins described how to read the script 200 times or more until he reaches the point of stability of dialogue in his mind,
Then they step away, let it grow in his mind, and when the scene arrives, relax
"Let the role play through you"
By controlling the ferries,
"Hopkins" is able to adapt the rhythm of words to get its efficiency
This phrase, for example, passed like this.
"I've seen a lot of you come and come back over the years." As is the first part of the following sentence even stand after "from"
The word "enjoy" that lies directly in an urgent performance slips over words,
Even the last two phrases, which are accompanied by communication with the eyes, and slower to be filled as a charge.
I've seen a lot of you come and come back over the years. I can say that those who enjoy the time here and those who do not enjoy it.
I like it.
By its own management.
A small objection
But you see how it opens like a rose that was curved, how to release a little tension to receive congratulations. Great touch.
I came here once when I was a child with my parents. I think we also sat at this table.
When I started working here, I realized that this place was not something to enjoy
Then we get a second of the objection when the accusation is confirmed followed by a bend again, and a shrunk neck.
Then, from this situation, Hopkins launched the key to talk
At first I imagined that things would become
Perfectly balanced.
I also had a bet with my partner "Arnold" on this effect
He made hundreds of successful scenarios. Of course, almost no one brings us up to them. She lost the bet.
Arnold always took a dim view of people. He favored the hosts.
He begged me not to make you money men involved with us.
"Deloth"
Well, "we are about to know that the interview is all a threat arranged by" Hopkins "
And the sign that, gradually summoned the threat through three terms and clarified who is threatening them.
"you are"
Listen to it again. He begged me not to make you participate with us.
Money men.
"Deloth"
I told him it was good that you did not understand what you were paying for.
It is not a commercial enterprise, not a theme park,
But a whole world.
We designed every inch of it
All leaf grass.
Here we were the gods
And you.
You were just visitors.
Watching this for the first time surprised me. How vital is the character of "Ford" in the serial performance.
I mean, "Westworld" in many ways is a ridiculous idea as a theme park and a chain.
To work, vanity must be a clear and justified scheme in the complex desires and ambitions of the originators.
The authors achieved this in the character of "Ford"
But he is "Hopkins" who went beyond those things to life.
And how this was done with Arnold
Sadly,
He lost his perspective.
Go mad.
I have not become mad, you all know, I always see things.
Very clearly
The threat is now very clear, Hopkins is painting the rest of the scene with a sinister tone
This table I sat on with my parents.
We know all about Zer, do not we? As we all know about our staff.
From here to the outside stands his pros, without guo but with satisfaction accompanied by his smile
There is no other need to convince Teresa of his compulsion
Hopkins passes through different directions in a few seconds before returning to that smile.
Just like here, about the truth
We know everything about visitors, do not we? As we all know about our staff.
Or here he is asking.
I hope you are careful with "Bernard"
Or here he cares sincerely and his eyes disdain for moments as well
He has a conscious disposition.
The serial producers are smart as they have set the camera on their face
His ability, learned through the decades to connect a network of emotions and to show
A world of emotions through whose personality we know little
And with the expansion of the scope and strength of the whole series and the power of persuading him as a piece of art
This is what the great actor can do
He can give words and fantasies or a short scene like this volcano of energy with a quiet look.
In the eyes and hands of "Hopkins" that "West World" is not lost the reflection of the personality of their makers
It's a self-image. You can say that the authors will finish writing in time
And it will not be as retroactive as you are afraid
I am not an emotional type.
Hi all, here is a video every Wednesday special "writer obsessed"
If you click here you will subscribe to the channel to get all the videos
Sorry I was a regular bug with the recent publication. I was in Italy.
It was a crazy trip.
But I also write after the speeches for the party that I will be in two weeks
So take me a lot of time and there is another channel I love her name "wisecrak"
They make gay but somewhat philosophical videos and made a video about "Bogak Horsman"
It's a series I love and the video was great and I will put the video down. Check it out
Thanks for watching. I'll see you all next Wednesday